fabrice di vizio merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france olivier ferrand on le
disait jérôme salomon et loire philippe
agnès buzyn cib et n'diaye à des pertes
y des perquisitions donc au domicile et
au bureau information judiciaire avec
comme chef d' abstention de combattre un
sinistre
c'est dans la logique d'une procédure
normale précis dans la logique
vous êtes des positions des clients là
maintenant et puis maintenant la lave
qui se fait soudain elle vient chercher
la vérité la cherche comme le disait
récemment donc on demande pas la vie
pour obtenir les documents qu'on revient
les chercher et on vient les chercher en
grande pompe en fanfare voilà c'est
toute la machine judiciaire qui se
déploie escalade impressionnante que la
plus solennelle mais aussi parce que
c'est nécessaire
le document vient chercher dans ces cas
là votre principalement les mails les
mémos qui ont pu être enregistrées
envoyé sous des bigoudis
elle a envoyé des mails et donc cessé
mais de la chercher en et de chercher
les ordinateurs
maintenant il va falloir les exploiter
et ensuite interroger les ministres sur
ce qu'on a trouvé alors beaucoup se sont
interrogés au niveau du timing avec des
perquisitions au lendemain des annonces
des manuels macron est ce que c'est un
simple hasard second sous lion
absolument vous animez un schéma vous
imaginez bien que trois magistrats la
cour de cassation une criminelle se sont
pas d'hier soir je pourrai plus de 10
dans un restaurant après le couvre-feu
et donc je vais décider à faire une
perquisition et je vais téléphoner cette
nuit ou deux
unité de police et de gendarmerie pour
les des péchés et donc c'était prévu du
temps alors évidemment ça tombe le
lendemain des attentes présentes de la
république
ça s'appelle la coïncidence est
effectivement c'est un très bon signal
envoyé politique un très bon signal
politique envoyé au président république
parce que c'est lui rappeler ses
rappeler au gouvernement qu'il est sous
le coup d'une enquête alors le gilbert
collard député européen proche du
rassemblement national a estimé sur lci
je le cite je vois vraiment dans cette
perquisition ordonnée au lendemain de la
déclaration du président de la
république par les plus hauts magistrats
une vraie déclaration de guerre de la
justice au pouvoir politique vous en
pensez quoi que je pense c'est que j'ai
des records à 1 peur pour lui que
gilbert collard tant que politique
prêche pour sa paroisse que gilbert
collard effectif plus simple en
d'ignorer ce quel système judiciaire
alors qu'il est avocat
moi je fais pas de politique je fais le
droit la couleur fait de la politique
pas de droit alors qu'est ce qu'on peut
attendre en tout cas de cette
information judiciaire qui s'ajoute à l'
enquête ouverte 10 juin par le parquet
de paris
que risquent les mises en cause
jusqu'où peut en attendre d'abord c'est
la vérité il a des rites et on a
toujours à craindre
ça c'est un point contestable et
effectivement pas clairement ce qui va
se passer c'est que ces procédures aller
à son terme et à ce terme la commission
a trop qui nous dira si oui ou non il ya
des fautes pénales qui ont été commises
s'il y en a les ministres se complique
s'il y en a par n ont pas très bien à
100 là on considérera capable mais au
moins on sera allé au bout et on aura
fait la vérité sur cette affaire
une vérité à propos de laquelle je
répète que la justice était la seule à
pouvoir la faire on met de côté l'aspect
juridique selon vous est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on a assez de recul sur
cette crise sanitaire inédite pour mener
l enquête et voir là où il aurait dû
prendre des mesures
la justice et pas besoin de recul
tant et si bien que vous avez vu les
enquête de flagrance la justice et pas
besoin de recul
au contraire la justice agit dans le
temps de la traction ces mêmes vous
allez même d'ailleurs vous savez
aujourd'hui au parquet vous avez un
système qui s'appelle de traitement en
temps réel le ttr aujourd'hui au
contraire l'heure et de la réponse
pénale dans le temps de l'infraction et
pas avec le recul de l'action c'est
aujourd'hui qu'ils vont quêter pas dans
dix ans merci beaucoup fabrice di vizio
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes avocat